this is grand master daniel nardiski
we're watching the world champion take
on greek grand master demetrius master
vasilis at the 2021 fide world rapid and
blitz and magnus as saying a close
sicilian potentially knight c3 could
lead to a lot of different things but
now he plays knight f3 will he transpose
back into a regular sicilian maestro
basilis playing the teimanav setup and
there's d4 so they've transposed back
into a regular sicilian queen c7 would
lead to the taemon of a6 is another
version of that move now magnus has many
many options in this position white
literally has eight or nine viable
setups and you can see the world
champion fidgeting with probably the
pawn that he's just captured as he
decides what set up to play bishop e3
bishop e2 g3 literally any developing
move except bishop d3 perhaps
is a possible system and magnus taking
quite a bit of time to decide what he
wants to play here and he plays g2 g4
one of the most aggressive systems
available in this move has been very
popular recently and master vasilis
did i sent a little bit of surprise at
that move i can definitely see that move
being played in some top tournaments
these days let's see what the greek
grand master has in store for a knight
g7 is possible here now the idea of g4
is to push that pawn up to g5 as quickly
as possible so the move knight f6 right
now would walk right into the idea of
that move you don't want to develop that
g8 knight to f6 master vasilis he trades
on d4 and will he play knight e7 knight
c6 no he plays b7 b5 a typical sicilian
move preparing uh action on the queen
side and magnus hesitating there will he
play a3 to stop b4
no he gets his dark squared bishop out
to e3 allowing muster bustilus to push
his pawn to b4 if he wants to but the
drawback of playing b4 would be that it
allows knight a4 and knight b6 so i
don't think that the greek gm should
push that beep on any further and he
does not he develops his own light squad
bishop magnus castle and queen side he
seems very relaxing he seems confident
and that queen on d4 could be really
intimidating so that g8 knight where is
it going to go how is master vasilis
going to develop his g89 will he play
knight g8 to e7 to c6 in order to try to
chase the white queen away from d4 and
involve that knight in the queen side
attack that's the idea that i've seen in
this line but he continues to take his
time rook c8 maybe also possible
yep he plays rook c8 but he's not really
preparing bishop c5 because then the g7
pawn is going to be hanging so i still
think that he's gonna have to deal one
way or another with the white queen on
d4 but mac is playing f3 which enables
bishop c5 now bishop c5 is possible
because then queen takes g7 hangs the
bishop on e3 with check so bishop c5
would necessitate queen d2 and master
vasil is taking that opportunity
developing his bishop to c5
queen drops back to d2 and will we have
a trade of lights of dark squared
bishops here well the dragon of that for
black would be that the d6 square would
be really weak and so everything here
has a drawback it seems like dimitro is
here a little bit uncomfortable with his
position as he can see him hesitating
and he does go for the trade of bishops
queen takes e3
for a sicilian the game is moving very
slowly in a positional direction what
about queen d4 now attacking g7 and also
taking d7
under white's eye
that could be an unpleasant move because
then that black could be unable to
castle and magnus does exactly that
queen e3 to d4 now with black castles he
hangs the d7 pawn with a fork against
black's two minor pieces that would be
completely unthinkable but how else does
demetrius defend the g7 one the move f7
f6
if we have ben finally go into the room
we know he'll be disapproving of that's
a really really weakening move which
creates a lot of holes on the on the
king side d6 square is also a hole and
master of steel doesn't have anything
going yet on the queen side it seems
like he's gotten the shorter end of the
stick here out of the opening but can he
wheel himself out of this situation as
he bites the bullet plays f6 there was
no other good way to defend g7 and how
does magnus improve his position first
of all magnus still needs to complete
his development his light squad bishop
is still on its initial square will he
bring it out to e2 or g2 will he keep
pushing his kingside pawns with f4 a lot
of decisions here to be made by the
world champion magnus leans back in his
chair you can see the deliberation the
thought that goes into every move even
in a blitz game as he hesitates and he
does play bishop b2 not not the most
active move but it does connect the
rooks and it does in some cases prepare
f3 f4 and master muscle is getting his
queen out putting it on c7 putting
pressure on white's c2 pawn now if the
knight moves magnus would get checkmated
i don't think he's going to move the
knight he doesn't have any plans to do
that but he can also play rook d2 in
order to lend a little bit of
reinforcement to that c2 pawn so that
his knight would would be free to roam
about the cabin black could then play
knight e7 to c6 that idea is still on
the table chasing white's queen away
from d4 magnus making the typical
prophylactic move king b1 getting the
king out of the x-ray of the queen and
the rook
and i still think the black's position
is quite uncomfortable black still
cannot castle because you still give up
the d7 upon knight not c6 but g6 what an
interesting maneuver the knight going to
the weak dark square on f4 but magnus
striking at the other side with a2 a4
great move by magnus now that b5 pawn is
under pressure from three different
sources and if black has to take on a4
then that weakens the entire queenside
master vasilis he tries to defend it
with bishop c6 but doesn't that give
upon no a takes it a takes a very
creative way
of defending taking on b5 would give up
the c2 pawn but magnus playing queen b4
another great response threatening
bishop takes b5 and my worry is that
master vasilis is about to lose that b
bond and he still cannot castle now
because it would be illegal the queen on
b4 controls the f8 square queen b4 is a
nasty move and that will will that
knight on g6 move into f4 master vasilis
has to find the best way to sacrifice
the pawn on b5 he has to part ways
within ghost queen e5 but what if magnus
takes that pawn with his knight what if
magnus takes that pawn with his knight
and now the knight is heading to d6 this
is big trouble for master vasilis and if
he takes the knight then madness
recaptures with his bishop and the d7
pawn is going to be hanging and that
pressure is going to be unbearable and
rook b8 is played by master vasilis but
now knight d6 jack knight d6 check looks
like it almost wins the game but then
black is going to go king e8 to e7
master of seos might hang on even though
magnus had discovered check possibility
there
is there a knockout blow after knight d6
king e7 well we're about to find out
because magnus has played knight d6 king
e7
and bishop b5 would have moved
intercepting intercepting the rook and
bishop takes b5 loses the queen to
knight c4 i don't know if australis has
a move here he can't move his king
because of the fork on f7 and he takes
on b5 but now knight c4 wins the queen
knight c4 wins the queen and magnus a
little consternation but he finds a
knight c4 check and he's going to pick
up the queen because the king is in
check there's no way to block d6 and
knight takes e5 and everything is
collapsing and monster facilis resigns a
masterful display by the world champion
once again
if you like videos like this make sure
to click the link in the playlist thank
you so much for watching